sourit à daniel
moreno martin dès qu'il y aura des
scieries haut-karabagh libye mais aussi
chypre ou encore irak depuis le coup
d'état militaires ratés de 2016 le
président turc recep tayyip erdogan
adopte un discours martial et multiplie
les interventions militaires à l'égard
de plusieurs pays de la région son
objectif entretenir l'image d'un leader
fort qui se bat pour son pays et
s'imposer comme un leader régional
incontournable cette stratégie agressive
et elle payante que vos l'armée turque
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il y a quatre ingrédients essentiels
pour faire une bonne armée tout d'abord
les soldats
le classement militaire gfp place la
turquie au 11e rang des puissances
militaires mondiales avec lui cent mille
hommes 1,5 millions si l'on inclut les
réservistes et les personnels assimilés
la turquie dispose du deuxième
contingent le plus important au sein de
l'otan derrière les etats unis flattant
un nationalisme exacerbé
erdogan profite du fort sentiment
patriotique intimement ancré dans les
mentalités pour faire grossir les rangs
de l'armée le service militaire est
vécue comme une grande aventure pour les
appeler c'est un rite de passage
obligatoire avant de se lancer dans la
vie active
pourtant l'armée turque que revient de
loin en 1938 à la mort du fondateur de
la république turque mustafa kemal
atatürk elle occupe une place
prépondérante dans le fonctionnement
institutionnel du pays mais en 2003 à
l'arrivée au pouvoir du parti islamo
conservateur à cap et la donne change
rachael tayyip erdogan s'attaque à
l'héritage kémaliste il des militarise
les institutions renforce le pouvoir des
civils dans les instances décisionnelles
décapite la chaîne de commandement de
l'armée le but c'était aussi de se
protéger d'une éventuelle dissolution
dans le passé tous les partis qui
étaient jugés par le pouvoir militaire
communs étant suffisamment laïque été
dissous lui en juillet 2016 le putsch
avorté imputée à l'ex ali d'erdogan le
prédicateur fethullah gulen abouti à une
nouvelle série de purges le grand ménage
touche au moins 40% des hauts gradés
d'après les chiffres de l' agence
gouvernementale à latouille elle douanes
devient la clé de voûte de l'armée le
pouvoir civil et très influent donc ça
leur permet aussi de mieux contrôler et
l'intégration sont de l'armée du corps
des militaires mieux contrôler et
l'intégration au sein de l'armée mais
aussi former une nouvelle génération
d'officiers à la solde de l'état dès
l'été 2016 erdogan entame la
remilitarisation du pays ils recrutent
de nouveaux soldats et les dote de
meilleurs moyens matériels sur le plan
matériel aussi la turquie tente de
rattraper son retard d'après l'institut
international de recherche sur la paix
les dépenses militaires de la turquie
tourner autour de 14 milliards de
dollars en 2016 en 2017 ce chiffre passe
à 15 milliards puis il avoisine les 19
milliards en 2018 20 milliards en 2019
avant de baisser à 17 milliards en 2020
les dépenses militaires turcs
représentent près de 2,7 pour cent du
pib ce qui en fait le 16e pays le plus
dépensier au monde c'est encore bien
loin des etats-unis premiers de ce
classement en 2020 les dépenses
militaires américaines sont estimés à 7
178 milliards de dollars soit 3 7% du
pib la france 8e dépensier militaire au
monde a investi 52 27 milliards de
dollars dans son armée en 2020 soit 2,1
pour cent du pib malgré une augmentation
quasi constante de son budget militaire
depuis 2016 la turquie se situe donc
encore bien loin des plus grandes
puissances militaires elle doit en outre
composer avec un aléa de taille qui
freine son importations d'armements ses
relations diplomatiques trouble et
parfois même avec ses propres alliés en
2019 les etats unis n'excluent de son
programme d'avions de chasse f-35 sont
chasseurs de combat de 5e génération en
cause le choix d'arte de gan d'acheter
des missiles sol air à la russie la même
année paris et berlin suspendre leurs
exportations d'armes vers la turquie
suite à l'offensive menée par erdogan
dans le nord de la ci en 2021 c'est au
tour du canada d'annuler un contrat
d'armement à cause de l'implication
turque dans le haut-karabagh un contexte
international de défiance donc qui prive
la turquie d'importantes importations
d'armes mais qui a pour effet
d'accentuer sa politique d' autonomie
stratégique
aujourd'hui le pays produit 70% de son
armement d'après l'institut
international de recherche sur la paix
entre 2016 et 2020 la turquie a augmenté
de 30% ses exportations d'armes tout en
diminuant ses importations de 59% avions
de combats sous-marins frégate mais
aussi et surtout drones fin septembre le
salon aéronautique techno fest que la
turquie présente comme le plus grand du
monde a été l'occasion de mettre en
avant la grande fierté de l'industrie
militaire turque les drones de combat
bayraktar tb 2
ils sont conçus par l'entreprise privée
bay car dont le directeur technique
n'est autre que le gendre d'erdogan en
syrie en libye et dans le haut-karabagh
ils se sont avérées d'une efficacité
redoutable détruisant chars véhicules
blindés et dépôts de munitions en
augmentant considérablement les
ressources humaines et matérielles de
l'armée erdogan se donne les moyens de
déployer sa stratégie militaire
offensive avec les réformes
organisationnelles post coup d'état de
2016 une complète redéfinition du rôle
de l'armée s'opère désormais elle n'est
plus centrée sur la politique intérieure
il ya aussi un alignement fait de la
politique étrangère à la vision que elle
doit le président a du rôle de la
turquie en tant que puissance régionale
observé line une militarisation de la
politique
étrangère une militarisation de la
politique étrangère qui se matérialise
par l'intervention phare août 2016 dans
le nord de la syrie pour éradiquer le
dernier verrou de l'état islamique mais
également repoussé les forces kurdes en
2020 la turquie vole au secours du
gouvernement d'union national libyen et
chasse de tripoli les troupes militaires
du maréchal haftar sans oublier le haut
karabakh en septembre 2020 ou la turquie
participent à l'offensive victorieuse de
bakou contre les arméniens à la
politique du zéro problème avec les
voisins du d des années 2000 se
substitue donc un aventurisme militaire
sur fond de tensions avec l'europe et
les états unis cela pousse la turquie à
se tourner vers de nouveaux alliés
membres historiques de l'otan depuis
1952 la turquie revendique à la fois son
ancrage dans l'alliance occidentale mais
également une politique indépendante en
2019 le contentieux autour de l'achat de
batteries de missiles russes s 400 a
laissé des traces pour autant erdogan
n'entend pas faire machine arrière sa
rencontre fin septembre à sotchi avec
vladimir poutine illustre les bonnes
relations qu'entretiennent les deux pays
concernant les autres acteurs régionaux
la turquie tente de reconstituer son
influence en asie centrale elle exporte
des équipements de défense à plusieurs
pays egypte bahreïn irak qatar et arabie
saoudite
elle exporte également de l'armement
vers des pays sunnites en asie pacifique
tels que la malaisie le pakistan et
l'indonésie
malgré les purges à répétition entre
2003 et 2016 la turquie déploie des
efforts considérables depuis cinq ans
elle vise à construire une armée et une
industrie de défense entièrement
autonome même si elle peine encore à
rivaliser avec les plus grandes
puissances militaires mondiales
[Musique]